said we plan
it's hardest tonight I'm gonna chill
I only get to go to Charlotte two times
a year
somebody paid they money to come watch
me play
like not trying to be arrogant like it's
a bunch of kids in there my shoes and my
jersey
and just because we playing Charlotte on
NBA league pass on a Monday then ain't
nobody can watch it I I'm chilling
tonight
that's not what the the great players
the best players do
so the way y'all compete in the middle I
loved it
shots or fouls would still be the same
that's basketball
but then you can't go on the side that's
like ah we ain't playing them they still
watching
they still evaluating they didn't come
to see me play Apollo Brad
they do what we can do
y'all y'all next
so just keep that in mind like
right Claire not big game not big game
like
compete play basketball because
don't fix it for granted